Tief in den deutschen Wäldern
lebt ein ungebetener Hausgast.
Das sibirische Streifenhörnchen
steht auf der Liste ...
Warte mal, stopp.
Nein, nein, nein, Moment.
Erst mal: Eichhörnchen, sehr süß,
und Naturdokus: Ich lieb's, wirklich.
Aber jetzt, wo Julian Reichelt
wieder viel Zeit hat,
um ohne Tempolimit
über die Autobahn zu ballern,
brauchen wir doch ein neues Bollwerk
gegen die Meinungsdiktatur!
Aber doch nicht mit Wissenschaft -
oder?
Leute, ich sag's nur, wie's ist:
Es ist jetzt Zeit für knallharten
wissenschaftlichen Konsens.
Und deswegen erklär ich euch jetzt,
warum Wissenschaft
keine Demokratie ist.
(Flotte Musik)
# Sci-sci-science.
(Jubel)
Hallo, herzlich willkommen
bei "MAITHINK X"!
Mein Name ist Mai Thi Nguyen-Kim und
ich freu mich, dass ihr dabei seid.
Danke schön!
Vielen Dank.
Leute,
wir haben keine Zeit für so was,
wir müssen direkt loslegen.
Wir haben heute viel vor.
Erst mal hallo, Freunde der Sonne.
- (alle:) Hi, Mai!
Wahnsinn. Als hättet ihr's eingeübt!
(Gelächter)
Wie schön, dass ihr hier seid
bei der allerersten Folge
"MAITHINK X - Die Show".
Bei "Wissenschaftsshow"
denken die meisten,
also vor allem das ZDF-Publikum,
natürlich an ... so was.
(Knall, erschrockene Rufe)
Danke, Thora Schubert!
Nein, nein. Stopp.
Ihr braucht gar nicht zu klatschen,
es tut mir Leid, wenn ihr so was
erwartet: Das wird's nicht geben.
Wir machen hier
keine Elefantenzahnpasta.
Wir schmeißen auch
kein Trockeneis in Wasser.
Bei "MAITHINK X" geht es um
gesellschaftlich
und politisch relevante Themen.
Wir gehen ins Detail,
wir differenzieren.
Für Quatsch haben wir keine Zeit.
(Flotte Musik)
Für ein bisschen Quatsch
haben wir schon Zeit,
aber jetzt brauche ich
eure volle Aufmerksamkeit.
Auch hier im Studio, ne?
Wie heißt du?
- Maurice.
Maurice, ne?
(Gelächter)
Handy bleibt in der Tasche.
Ich pass auf.
Mach ich.
- Okay.
Aufmerksamkeit
ist in der heutigen Medienlandschaft
nämlich sehr wichtig,
aber auch begrenzt.
Wer hat zum Beispiel bemerkt,
dass ich andere Schuhe trage,
seit die Chemikerin da war?
Aha!
(Gelächter)
Die meiste Aufmerksamkeit bekommt,
was am lautesten knallt.
Mein geschätzter Kollege
Ranga Yogeshwar
nennt das "Erregungsbewirtschaftung".
Erregungsbewirtschaftung
ist inzwischen
zu einem erheblichen Bestandteil
unserer Medienlandschaft geworden.
Es geht nämlich um Aufmerksamkeit,
und die bekommt man durch Aufregung,
Empörung, Zuspitzung
oder durch Hasstiraden.
Hauptsache das Ganze wird angeklickt,
denn dann wird auch verdient.
Erregung gibt nämlich mehr Klicks
als die sachliche Information,
der differenzierte Dialog - und den
brauchen wir als Gesellschaft.
Also: Viel Glück, Mai.
Danke.
Danke, Ranga.
Aber Glück brauch ich gar nicht,
bei ZDFneo schaut ja eh niemand zu.
(Gelächter)
"Sex verkauft sich" war mal, heute
gilt: Provokation verkauft sich.
Doch auch Wissenschaft profitiert
neuerdings von dieser Aufmerksamkeit,
weil Wissenschaft
anscheinend auch provoziert.
Sobald die Wissenschaft
irgendwas sagt,
gibt es
eine wachsende Gruppe an Menschen,
die sofort Ausschlag kriegt und
reflexartig nach Freiheit schreit:
"Hallo, ist ein freies Land,
ich lass mir doch von Virologen nicht
verbieten, an Klobrillen zu lecken!"
Ja, ihr lacht.
Ich wünschte auch, es wär 'n Witz.
# Lick it up!
# Oh-oh ...
Nee, dafür klatschen wir nicht.
Nein, nein.
Das haben wirklich Leute gemacht.
In den USA.
Na ja, ne? "Die dummen Amis".
Deutschland ist natürlich ein Land
der Wissenschaft und Vernunft.
Immer, wenn jemand ankommt und sagt:
"Die Wissenschaft sagt ...",
ist man klug beraten,
zu hinterfragen,
was dieser grade im Schilde führt.
Äh ... Was soll das denn bedeuten?
Denn die Wissenschaft
hat immer auch Mindermeinungen.
Und wenn es ein Einzelner ist.
Nee nee, Moment.
Das ist doch ne völlig falsche
Darstellung von Wissenschaft.
Wie ...
Was, haben Sie da Widerspruch?
Ja, ich habe Widerspruch!
Dann kommen Sie bitte hier nach vorne
und erklären Ihr
Wissenschaftsverständnis,
dass Wissenschaft immer
hundert Prozent eine Meinung hat.
Sie haben den Kern von Wissenschaft
nicht verstanden,
wenn Sie das ernsthaft glauben.
Ich glaube, Sie haben den Kern
von Wissenschaft nicht verstanden!
(Gelächter)
Wer war das eigentlich? Egal.
Gut, dann erklär ich jetzt eben
mein Wissenschaftsverständnis!
Ich bin ja eh grad hier.
Hab nix anderes vor. Und ihr?
Maurice, hast du Zeit?
- Ja!
Gut.
Dann sprechen wir heute darüber,
warum Wissenschaft
keine Demokratie ist,
und warum das auch gut so ist.
Also.
Wenn jemand verlangt, doch bitte
auf die Wissenschaft zu hören,
kommt oft als Antwort:
"Die" Wissenschaft
gibt es so wenig wie "die" Politik.
Erst mal stimmt das natürlich.
Es gibt ja noch nicht mal ...
"das ZDF".
Sonst sähe "MAITHINK X" so aus.
Herzlich willkommen
bei "MAITHINK X - Die Show".
(Gelächter)
Was es aber gibt,
ist wissenschaftlicher Konsens.
Doch der wird katastrophal
missverstanden.
Nein, wissenschaftlicher Konsens
heißt nicht,
dass alle Wissenschaftler
einer Meinung sind.
Aber um das wirklich zu verstehen
brauchen wir erst ein paar Basics.
Fangen wir an mit der
Grundvoraussetzung für Wissenschaft:
wissenschaftliches Denken,
auch kritisches Denken genannt.
Und das erklären euch jetzt
zwei liebe Freunde von mir.
Okay.
Drei Beispiele für kritisches Denken.
Wenn man in Köln
über die Straße läuft
und in was Braunes, Weiches tritt,
das auch noch abartig stinkt,
dann ist es wahrscheinlich
Hundescheiße.
Oder an Karneval vielleicht auch
die Scheiße von einem Mittvierziger
mit Verdauungsproblemen
in einem völlig abgeranzten
Zebrakostüm.
Na ja,
es könnte auch Schokolade sein.
Ockhams Rasiermesser.
Bei mehreren möglichen Erklärungen
gilt:
Je weniger Annahmen
getroffen werden müssen,
desto wahrscheinlicher
ist die Erklärung korrekt.
Ein Hund kackt auf die Straße:
eine Annahme.
Jemand erfindet Schokolade,
die nach Kacke riecht
aber nach Schokolade schmeckt,
und verteilt die überall da,
wo du dann reintrittst:
Das sind ganz schön viele Annahmen.
Ockhams Rasiermesser
ist manchmal etwas schwierig,
weil Populisten damit
einfache Antworten
auf komplexe Probleme versprechen.
Kannst du noch mal planschen?
Dadurch sind meine Kopfschmerzen
besser geworden.
"Post hoc ergo propter hoc"-
Fehlschluss,
Latein für: "danach, also deswegen".
Nur weil etwas nacheinander passiert,
ist das eine nicht automatisch
die Ursache des anderen.
Und warum sind meine Kopfschmerzen
dann weg?
Weil Kopfschmerzen
halt irgendwann weggehen,
oder wann hattest du
lebenslange Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, vielleicht hast du recht.
Ich muss dann auch jetzt mal los.
Ich hab nämlich letztens
bei einer AfD-Ortsgruppe gedreht,
und da meinten welche,
dass die da oben mit Hotel-WLANs
unsere Gedanken kontrollieren.
Die mischen da
irgendne Strahlung ins Signal,
die nicht mal 'n Namen hat,
weil Physiker
die vor uns geheimhalten wollen.
Also eine neuartige Strahlung,
die niemand kennt
außer der AfD-Ortsgruppe? - Genau.
(Gelächter)
So ne Scheiße würden ja nicht mal
die Abonnenten von Michael Wendlers
Telegramkanal glauben.
Das ist unsere Meinung,
aber die glauben,
das wär ne wissenschaftliche Theorie.
Und dass die ja wohl jemand wider-
legen würde, wenn sie falsch wäre.
Eine Theorie,
die nicht falsifizierbar ist,
also nicht geprüft
oder widerlegt werden kann,
kann auch nicht bestätigt werden.
Dass niemand diese komische Strahlung
widerlegen kann
ist also kein Beleg dafür,
dass sie existiert.
Oh, der feine Herr hat studiert.
Aber mal ganz kurz:
Hast du eigentlich immer
dein Kamerateam dabei?
Boah, du bist so ein Streber.
Deswegen mag der Welke
mich lieber als dich.
So, wir müssen los.
Karl Lauterbach gibt nämlich jetzt
ne Pressekonferenz
zum Thema "Aerosole im Spa-Bereich".
Ab geht's!
(Applaus)
Danke, Lutz van der Horst
und Fabian Köster.
Das waren jetzt nur
drei Beispiele für kritisches Denken,
aber wenn man die ablehnt,
ist das quasi schon
das Basis-Legoset "Flacherde".
Ja, Verschwörungserzählungen
sind kinderleicht. Passt auf:
Äpfel fallen manchmal nach oben.
Aber natürlich nur,
wenn niemand hinguckt.
Und jetzt widerleg mir das mal,
Maurice.
Eben, kannste nicht.
Da brauchen wir erst gar nicht
mit Vernunft
und rationalen Argumenten anfangen:
Ohne kritisches Denken
ist kein rationaler Diskurs möglich.
Und zwar nicht nur
bei wissenschaftlichen Themen,
sondern auch bei gesellschaftlichen
und politischen.
Was Wissenschaft
aber einzigartig macht,
ist das wissenschaftliche Arbeiten.
Und da fehlt uns einiges
an Allgemeinbildung.
Wenn in der Öffentlichkeit
über Studien gesprochen wird,
dann meistens nur über
einen kleinen Teil: die Ergebnisse.
Da findet man nämlich auch immer
etwas Schlagzeilenwürdiges.
"Studie:
Männer denken 34 Mal am Tag an Sex"
Hip-Hop-Musik verbessert Käse-Aroma"
"Neue Studie: Deshalb solltest du
am Furz deines Partners riechen"
Das sind alles
echte Schlagzeilen übrigens.
Gut, die geben die echten Studien
nicht so ganz korrekt wieder,
aber na ja, wenn man alle Details
miteinbezieht wird's direkt unsexy.
Hier, die Furzstudie:
"Freisetzung von Schwefelwasserstoff
direkt am Mitochondrion
erweist sich als interessant
für weitere Forschung."
Hat nichts mit Pupsen zu tun.
Lol, Pups.
Wer will denn so was lesen?
Wer hat denn Zeit
für die ganzen Details?
Wobei, ihr hattet ja nix vor, ne?
(Gelächter)
Ich seh's doch in euren Augen, 'n
bisschen Bock habt ihr schon, oder?
Ja, das wussten wir natürlich!
Und deshalb haben wir extra
eine Rubrik dafür,
und wie die heißt sagen euch jetzt
the three and only:
Fettes Brot.
# Nerdy!
# Nerdy by nature!
Merksatz für alle zum Mitschreiben:
Studie ist nicht gleich Studie.
Ihr müsst übrigens
nicht wirklich mitschreiben,
ihr könnt alles noch mal in Ruhe
samt Quellen hier nachlesen.
Eine Studie
kann richtig starke Evidenz liefern,
also richtig starke Belege
und Beweise.
Kugelsicher wie das Papamobil,
das Batmobil
oder das Ego von Christian Lindner.
(Gelächter)
Eine Studie kann aber auch total aus
der Luft gegriffener Bullshit sein.
Wie Wirecard-Aktien, Scooter-Texte
oder das Ego von Christian Lindner.
(Gelächter)
Bullshit gibt es überall,
auch in der Wissenschaft.
Nur wie unterscheidet man
gute Studien und schlechte Studien,
also starke Evidenz
und schwache Evidenz?
Indem man sich die Methoden ansieht,
also die Art und Weise, wie die Daten
erhoben und ausgewertet wurden.
Nehmen wir die Schlagzeile
"Männer denken 34 Mal am Tag an Sex".
Ist ja erst mal interessant, ne?
Sagen wir, man ist 16 Stunden wach,
geteilt durch 34,
also etwa jede halbe Stunde.
Die Sendung geht jetzt
so zwölf, 13 Minuten.
Maurice ...
Du weißt,
was wir jetzt alle fragen wollen.
Nämlich:
Wie haben die Forschenden gemessen,
wie oft die Männer an Sex denken, ne?
Es gibt ja viele Methoden, das
menschliche Gehirn zu untersuchen:
MRT, EEG, PET und vieles mehr.
Mit diesen Geräten
kann man Aktivitäten in Hirnregionen
oder auch Hirnströme messen.
Aber es gibt keins,
das Gedanken lesen kann.
Zum Glück.
Ne, Maurice?
Stattdessen
muss man Menschen befragen,
um deren Gedanken zu erfahren.
Und ihr könnt euch ja selbst denken,
wie verlässlich so ein "Wie oft
denkst du an Sex?"-Fragebogen ist.
Menschen neigen dazu,
selbst bei anonymen Befragungen
nicht ganz ehrlich zu sein.
Eine Frau, die zweimal pro Stunde
an Sex denkt, könnte weniger angeben,
weil weiblicher Sexualtrieb
immer noch stigmatisiert ist.
Bei Männern
kann's genau andersrum sein.
Das nennt man
Social Desirability Bias.
Und dieser Effekt
kann die Befragung verzerren.
In dieser Studie hat man aber
nicht nur einen Fragebogen benutzt,
sondern die Proband:innen zusätzlich
mit solchen Handzählern ausgestattet.
Die sollten sie
sieben Tage lang bei sich tragen
und jedes Mal, wenn sie
an Sex dachten, draufklicken.
Und dabei kam raus,
dass die Männer im Durchschnitt
34 Mal pro Tag an Sex dachten,
die Frauen etwa 19 Mal.
Aber die Spanne, wie oft
die Proband:innen an Sex dachten,
war riesig.
Bei Männern reichte sie
von einmal pro Tag an Sex gedacht
bis zu 388 Mal an Sex gedacht.
(Schnelles Klacksen, Gelächter)
(Applaus)
(Räuspern)
Kann natürlich auch sein,
dass man möglicherweise
'n bisschen mehr an Sex denkt,
wenn man einen fucking Handzähler
dabei hat,
der einen daran erinnert,
dass man vielleicht an Sex denkt.
So oder so:
Ein Durchschnittswert
bei einer Spanne von eins bis 388
ist ziemlich nutzlos.
Ihr seht also:
Wissenschaftliche Ergebnisse sagen
wenig aus, solange man nicht weiß,
auf welchem Weg sie entstanden sind.
Aber ihr wisst das jetzt,
und könnt diese Schlagzeile jetzt
gleich viel besser einordnen.
In diesem Fall also mit: "Na ja."
# Nerdy!
# Nerdy by nature!
Selbst wissenschaftliche Methoden
können also mit größeren
Unsicherheiten behaftet sein.
Müssen aber nicht.
In der chemischen Forschung
zum Beispiel
kann man Moleküle auch
in eine Art Hirnscanröhre schieben,
und aus der Schwingung der Atome im
Magnetfeld ergibt sich ein Spektrum,
aus dem man
die chemische Struktur ablesen kann.
Hier weiß man dann ganz sicher,
so sieht das Molekül aus.
Da gibt's nichts zu diskutieren.
Also, über das Molekül schon,
das ist nämlich die Strukturformel
von Tetrahydrocannabinol.
Wir wissen alle:
"Nur weil Alkohol
gefährlich ist, unbestritten,
ist Cannabis kein Brokkoli."
(Gelächter)
"Okay?"
Okay. Aber das ist THC,
das ist sicher.
Wie wichtig Methodenverständnis ist,
sehen wir auch an Corona.
Die STIKO sagt,
wir sollen uns impfen lassen.
Dafür sagen diverse Einzelstimmen,
dass "alternative" Heilmittel
viel besser und sicherer seien.
Wem glauben,
wenn alle dabei behaupten,
die Wissenschaft
auf ihrer Seite zu haben?
Die Antwort liegt auch hier
in den Methoden.
Ob ein Coronaimpfstoff wirklich
wirksam und sicher ist,
muss man nämlich mit klinischen
Zulassungsstudien belegen,
die sogenannte randomisierte
kontrollierte Studien sind.
Ja, hier in den ersten Reihen
nicken die Streber schon.
Klar, randomisierte kontrollierte
Studie kennen und lieben wir.
Für alle, die kurz vergessen haben,
wie dieses Studiendesign aussieht,
hier ein Auffrischungsclip.
(Sanfte Musik)
(Gelächter)
Hallo.
Die randomisierte
kontrollierte Studien
gilt als der Goldstandard
in der medizinischen Forschung,
um den Effekt einer Behandlung
zu untersuchen.
Etwa den Effekt von Scooter-Musik
auf die emotionale Entwicklung
von jungen Erwachsenen.
So wird's gemacht, Schritt eins:
Man sucht sich eine möglichst
große Gruppe von jungen Erwachsenen.
Also, wir bräuchten dann
1.000 Proband:innen.
Und dann ...
Was? Nee, aber wir brauchen
doch mindestens ...
Also, ich kann das nicht ...
Äh, Hallo?
(seufzt:) Okay.
(Gelächter)
Sagen wir, ich zeig euch das
anhand von irgendwas,
was ich immer griffbereit habe,
wie diese Ananas.
Genau genommen 1.000 Anana- ...
(Räuspern)
(flüstert:) Zehn.
- Zehn Ananasse.
Zehn Ananasse.
(Gelächter)
Die Hypothese ist dann:
Scooter-Beschallung beschleunigt
die Reifung von Ananassen.
(Quietschen)
Ich wiederhole:
Scooter-Beschallung beschleunigt
die Reifung von Ananassen.
Schritt zwei:
Die Proband:innen
werden randomisiert.
Sprich, zufällig
in zwei Gruppen eingeteilt.
Sehr schön.
Zufällig! Zufällig.
(Gelächter)
(Lebhafte Musik)
Normalerweise
macht das ja ein Computer,
damit die Wissenschaftlerin
nicht bewusst oder unbewusst
die Auswahl beeinflusst.
Sonst wäre das eine Verzerrung.
Aber einen Computer haben wir nicht.
(Gelächter)
Nun haben wir eine Testgruppe
und eine Kontrollgruppe.
Randomisiert und kontrolliert.
Wichtig ist,
dass Test- und Kontrollgruppe
möglichst gut vergleichbar sind.
In unserem Test sollten also unsere
Probanden denselben Reifegrad haben.
Nun beginnen wir mit der Beschallung.
Beschallung.
Wir beginnen mit der Beschallung.
(Gelächter)
Idealerweise über einen
sehr langen Zeitraum.
(motiviert:) Yes, Langzeit!
- Langzeit.
(Laute Scooter-Musik)
- # Yeah!
(Grillenzirpen)
(Scooter-Musik)
# Sunshine in the air!
(Grillenzirpen)
(Scooter-Musik)
(Musik endet abrupt.)
(brüllt:) Also,
nach einiger Zeit schaut man ...
Ach so.
Nach einiger Zeit schaut man dann,
ob die Ananasse in der Testgruppe
genauso gereift sind
wie in der Kontrollgruppe.
(Gelächter)
Ah, das sieht statistisch
sogar sehr signifikant aus.
Aber was das bedeutet,
erklären wir euch ein anderes Mal.
Bis dahin: Science ist meins!
(Gelächter)
Und Cut.
(erleichtert:) Super, toll.
Das war's. Brauchst du noch was?
Endlich, ich schwitz wie ein Schwein.
(Unheilvolle Musik, Applaus)
Okay.
Ich weiß, ich weiß ...
Es sah ein bisschen albern aus,
es ist aber eine starke Methode.
Die randomisierte
kontrollierte Studie
gilt als methodisches Nonplusultra
in der medizinischen Forschung.
Und natürlich wurden
alle zugelassenen Coronaimpfstoffe
mit einem solchen Studiendesign
getestet.
Umgekehrt kann man an schlechten
Methoden auch Bullshit erkennen.
Gut, manchmal ist es einfach,
etwa bei magischen Fläschchen,
die angeblich vor Corona schützen,
indem man sie sich geschlossen
auf die Brust legt.
Oder die heilende Zahlenkombination
5-3-7-3-5-4,
die man möglichst
überall hinschreiben soll.
So einfach kann's sein.
Es gibt aber auch weniger
offensichtlich absurde "Heilmittel",
auf die einzelne "Experten" schwören,
teilweise mit Doktor-
oder Professortitel.
Beispiel: Chlordioxid-Lösung kann man
als Desinfektionsmittel kaufen,
etwa für Trinkwasser.
Ist in sehr geringen Mengen
also kein Problem.
Davon abgesehen sollte man das
aber nicht einnehmen
und auch nicht
seinen Kindern verabreichen!
Man sollte es nicht trinken,
man sollte nicht darin baden
und sich keine Einläufe damit machen,
oder was es sonst für Tipps gibt,
weil es angeblich bei Autismus,
Krebs oder COVID-19 hilft.
Das tut es nämlich nicht!
Und trotzdem raten "Experten" dazu,
weil es ja Studien gäbe.
Doch diese Studien sehen methodisch
beispielsweise so aus.
Man nimmt 20 Personen, die positiv
auf Corona getestet wurden.
Gibt denen verdünntes Chlordioxid
und guckt,
ob sie innerhalb von einem Monat
wieder negativ sind.
Genau dieses Studienvorhaben
wurde hier offiziell registriert.
Nur bringt es natürlich nichts,
denn bei 20 Probanden,
die nicht Hochrisikopatienten sind,
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass die 20 wieder gesund werden,
zum Glück sehr hoch.
Egal, ob man Chlordioxid geschluckt
oder sich ein Fläschchen
auf die Brust gelegt hat.
Post hoc ergo propter hoc,
wir erinnern uns.
Anders gesagt,
so eine Studie kann man machen.
Man kann's aber auch lassen,
denn schlauer wird man dadurch nicht.
Chlordioxid-"Experten" stellen sich
aber als kritische Denker dar,
die sich trauen,
gegen den Mainstream zu gehen.
Und viele Menschen glauben ihnen.
Und wisst ihr, wer schuld daran ist?
Ganz genau, Einstein.
(Gelächter)
Wait for it, macht gleich Sinn.
Einstein war ja auch
gegen den Mainstream.
Der hat alles hinterfragt.
Geglaubt hat ihm auch niemand.
Die allgemeine Relativitätstheorie
war ja auch total cray-cray, ne?
Raumzeit, Massen, die den Raum
krümmen, schwarze Löcher,
Zeit, die langsamer vergeht,
je schneller man sich bewegt -
das klang damals auch nicht weniger
verrückt als 5-3-7-3-5-4.
Und trotzdem ist Einstein bis heute
der am häufigsten auf T-Shirts
gedruckte Wissenschaftler.
Doch den Fame hat er nicht allein
der verrückten Idee zu verdanken.
Einstein hat nicht nur
wilde Thesen aufgestellt,
sondern auch direkt konkrete
Möglichkeiten mitgeliefert,
ihn zu widerlegen,
Stichwort Falsifizierbarkeit.
Man muss zum Beispiel
nur den Nachthimmel
mit dem Himmel
einer Sonnenfinsternis vergleichen,
weil die Sonne den Raum krümmt,
aber ich seh schon, Maurice,
du langweilst dich,
du weißt das alles schon.
Was kam dabei raus?
Einstein wurde nicht widerlegt,
sondern belegt.
Mehrmals übrigens, Evidenz.
Deswegen drucken wir ihn
heute auf T-Shirts.
Also ja, wissenschaftlicher Konsens
wird fortlaufend upgedatet.
Oder upgedatet? Geupdatet?
Na ja, aktualisiert, ihr wisst schon.
Wissenschaftlicher Konsens
ist nicht die Wahrheit,
sondern nur
die derzeit beste Näherung.
Aber allein das Hinterfragen
von wissenschaftlichem Konsens
macht dich nicht zu Einstein.
Den Unterschied zwischen
quergedachten Außenseitertheorien
und einer wissenschaftlichen
Revolution macht die Evidenz.
Und da Evidenz das ist,
was in der Wissenschaft zählt,
ist auch nicht jede Meinung
gleich stark.
Nicht jede Stimme wird gleich
gewichtet wie in einer Demokratie.
Sondern starke Evidenz
schlägt schwache Evidenz.
Wissenschaft ist keine Demokratie.
Nicht eine Mehrheit beschließt,
was die stärkste Evidenz sein soll,
sondern die stärkste Evidenz
versammelt eine Mehrheit hinter sich.
Nur kriegt diese Mehrheit nicht immer
die größte Aufmerksamkeit.
Wer Bild-Interviews gibt
oder bei Lanz sitzt,
folgt nicht automatisch
der stärksten Evidenz,
weil in den Medien
halt andere Regeln gelten.
Erregungsbewirtschaftung.
Und natürlich gilt das auch für mich,
ich will gar nicht,
dass ihr mir blind vertrauen müsst,
sondern dass ihr das,
was ich über Wissenschaft sage,
selbst einordnen könnt.
Und der Schlüssel dazu ist kritisches
Denken und Methodenverständnis.
Methodenverständnis
ist Empowerment für Laien.
Denn ich muss zwar Chemie studiert
haben, um das hier auszuwerten,
Aber ich muss nicht Chemie studiert
haben, um zu verstehen,
dass so was eine stärkere Evidenz ist
als das.
Ja, Empowerment für Laien.
So viel zu
Evidenz ist nicht gleich Evidenz,
beziehungsweise
Studie ist nicht gleich Studie.
Zweiter wichtiger Merksatz:
Eine Studie ist keine Studie.
Jede Studie ist nur ein Puzzleteil.
Was zählt, ist das Gesamtbild.
Starke Evidenz beruht also
nicht nur auf starken Methoden,
sondern auch darauf,
dass unterschiedliche Studien
zusammenpassen
und ein konsistentes Bild ergeben.
Beispiel: Wir Menschen sind
der Hauptgrund für den Klimawandel.
Da passt nach jahrzehntelanger
Forschung leider alles zusammen.
Temperaturmessungen,
Bohrkerne, Sedimentanalysen,
C-14-Isotopbestimmung der Atmosphäre
und vieles mehr.
Ich hör auf,
Maurice langweilt sich schon wieder.
Old News, ne?
Natürlich ist das Bild nicht immer so
klar, selbst in der Klimaforschung.
Zum Beispiel bei der Frage, wann
welche Kipppunkte auftreten werden,
also Ereignisse,
die dann nicht mehr umkehrbar sind.
Und bei manchen Forschungsfragen
werden wir vielleicht nie
ein klares Bild haben.
Zum Beispiel wie Liebe
biochemisch genau funktioniert.
Oder was außerhalb
des Universums ist.
Oder das Paradoxon,
warum überall Rosinen drin sind,
wenn sie doch keiner mag.
Übrigens liegt es meistens
an fehlenden starken Methoden,
warum wir
keine klaren Antworten kriegen.
Es gibt auch Fragen,
die noch zu neu sind,
um sie klar zu beantworten.
Zum Beispiel
wenn ein neues Coronavirus
plötzlich die Welt
auf den Kopf stellt.
Es ist für Laien,
die sich schnell klare Antworten
wünschen, frustrierend.
Da kann man den Eindruck bekommen,
dass es so was wie gesicherte
wissenschaftliche Erkenntnis
gar nicht gibt.
Doch selbst beim Thema Corona
gibt es Fragen, die geklärt sind,
über die nicht mehr gestritten wird.
Zum Beispiel, Fakt:
Viren können Krankheiten auslösen.
Es gibt leider tatsächlich
eine Bubble, die das nicht glaubt
und für die sich "Plandemie"
plausibler anhört.
Oder Fakt:
Noch nie gab es Impfstoffe,
deren Sicherheit und Nebenwirkungen
nach der Zulassung
so sorgfältig beobachtet wurden
wie die Coronaimpfstoffe.
Einfach weil noch nie
Millionen von Menschen
in so kurzer Zeit geimpft wurden.
Das schafft eine nie dagewesene
statistische Power,
um sogar sehr seltene Nebenwirkungen
überhaupt erst zu bemerken.
Kurz gesagt:
Nur weil sich Wissenschaft
um ungeklärte Fragen dreht,
heißt das nicht,
dass es gleichzeitig
nicht bereits geklärte Fragen gibt.
Und wenn man Letztere
anhand von starker Evidenz erkennt,
dann ist man hier klug beraten, eben
doch auf die Wissenschaft zu hören.
Und auch wenn Sätze wie "Wissenschaft
lebt von Widerspruch" oder ...
"Die" Wissenschaft
gibt es so wenig wie "die" Politik.
.. ohne Kontext
erst mal richtig sind,
sollten wir sie nicht als pauschales
Totschlagargument einsetzen,
um wissenschaftlichen Konsens
abzulehnen.
Zum Beispiel
weil er uns nicht gefällt.
Denn keine Sorge, Wissenschaft kann,
soll und will euch gar nicht sagen,
ob es richtig oder falsch ist,
an Klobrillen zu lecken.
Sie sagt euch nur,
was ihr da alles aufleckt.
Und nur wenn ihr das wisst,
könnt ihr wirklich frei entscheiden.
Random an Klobrillen lecken,
weil man es kann,
ist nicht Freiheit, sondern Willkür.
Deswegen sage ich: Wissenschaft
ist keine Einschränkung der Freiheit,
sondern genau das Gegenteil:
Aufklärung schafft Freiheit.
(Applaus)
Aber das ist jetzt nur meine Meinung,
mehr nicht,
darüber können wir
also gerne streiten,
aber über Schwerkraft bitte nicht.
Das war die erste Folge "MAITHINK X".
Nächste Woche geht es weiter
mit einem ganz anderen Thema,
was es ist verrate ich nicht, müsst
ihr selber gucken, bis dann, tschüss!
(Jubel)